[Musik]
frau von storch im aktuellen bundestag
sind so wenige frauen wie vor seit 20
jahren nicht mehr weshalb wir sind der
meinung dass die quote von frauen in
parlamenten nicht erforderlich ist jede
partei hat die möglichkeit so viele
frauen auf ihre liste zu stellen und sie
zu wählen wie sie möchte und man sollte
dem nicht mit irgendwelchen quoten
versuchen nachzuhelfen das halten wir
für grundfalsch das halten wir auch für
eine diskriminierung weil wir die
menschen nicht unterscheiden in ihren
geschlechtern und wir haben noch mal bei
der aufstellung der listen jeder die
möglichkeit zu kandidieren jeder hat das
gleiche recht es ist insgesamt ja so
dass frauen sich weniger in der politik
engagieren der anteil von frauen in den
parteien ist im allgemeinen sehr viel
geringer als der von männern obwohl die
frauen die gleichen rechte haben in eine
partei einzutreten und irgendwie ist es
verstößt sogar gegen meinem
gerechtigkeitsempfinden wenn sie
irgendwie zwölf männer und zwei frauen
auf drei plätze bewerben und dann eben
einfach nur wegen des geschlechtes die
zwei frauen die position beziehen und
ein platz sich unter zwölf herren
aufteilen muss wenn wir quoten für
frauen haben wollen dann muss sich jetzt
die frage stellen wer ist eigentlich
eine frau weil wir jetzt die gesetze
haben das selbstbestimmungsrecht des
geschlechtes das heißt frau ist wer sich
als frau definiert für wen gilt das wenn
denn für die für den mann der sich als
frau definiert was ist mit den diversen
haben wir auch quoten wie hoch ist die
quote
ich habe eine anfrage an die
bundesregierung gemacht wie viele
diverse gibt es denn jetzt nachdem das
dritte geschlecht eingeführt worden ist
es haben sich 275 personen als die werks
eintragen lassen
welche quoten haben die das ist das
funktioniert alles nicht und das ist
nicht gleichberechtigung sondern das ist
die aufspaltung der gesellschaft in
gruppen männer frauen das nächste ist
mit migrationshintergrund dann brauchen
wir eine quote für übergewichtige dann
brauchen wir eine wunde wir fangen an
die gesellschaft zu zerteilen und wir
vergessen dass jeder abgeordnete das
ganze volk repräsentiert der sitzt dort
nicht als vertreter einer gruppe dass es
mittelalterlicher ständestaat denn man
als person eine bestimmte gruppe einen
bestimmten stand eine bestimmtes
geschlecht eine bestimmte sexuelle
orientierung einem bestimmten
hintergrund migrations oder
zitate repräsentiert nein der
abgeordneten im deutschen bundestag der
repräsentiert das ganze volk und nicht
einen stand oder einen geschlecht oder
sonst was die frage warum so wenige
frauen in die politik
das ist die richtige frage die muss man
stellen und das ist das kann man jetzt
nicht einfach beantworten ich glaube
politik ist und ziemlich hartes geschäft
es mich immer sehr angenehm
es gibt viele auseinandersetzung es gibt
viel streit
es gibt ja auseinandersetzung das ist im
prinzip das in einer in einer weise die
vielleicht für frauen die er nicht
frauen typisch ist frauen mögen das
nicht so gerne
frauen sind eher harmoniebedürftig und
männer sind eher streithähne man kann
sagen das ist schade
man kann aber auch einfach sagen so ist
es eben männer und frauen sind
unterschiedlich und wenn sie mich fragen
gott sei dank wie langweilig wäre das
leben ohne die männer sage ich jetzt mal
und für die meisten männer und die
weißen frauen würden das auch sagen ich
wir wollen doch keine männer die wie
frauen sind und die meisten frauen
wollen keine keine keine die männer
wollen keine frauen die männer sind und
umgekehrt
das leben wäre sehr langweilig sie sind
unterschiedlich so ist es in dem
sozialen medien werden viele
politikerinnen gerade mit hass mails
bombardiert passiert ihnen das auch ich
kriege hass-mails jede menge
ich kriege us-post jede menge bezieht
das aber nicht auf das geschlecht
sondern ganz allgemein werden wir die
ganze zeit attackiert auch dass hass und
hetze wie es dann immer heißt sich
unabhängig vom geschlecht natürlich gibt
es anfeindungen gegen frauen es gibt
frauenfeindliche witze die ekelhaft sind
usw
das ist nicht schön das muss nicht sein
aber ich sag mal so die männer sind
insofern spricht das nicht für die
männer aber ich will da raus jetzt
keinen keinen geschlechterkampf machen
ich glaube dass wir wirklich ernsthafte
probleme haben darum sollten wir uns
kümmern
aber wenn sie solche mails bekommen wir
reagieren wie wenn ich hass mails
bekomme dann lösche ich die mails ich
weiß natürlich dem hass nicht ich halte
dem stand und wenn es sich lohnt dann
antworte ich aber bei einem hass und bei
reiner beleidigung lohnte sich nicht
sagen
ich habe keine angst in der politik ich
weiß dass ich angegangen werde ich weiß
dass ich angegriffen werde
ich sorge vor ich schütze mich ich habe
also der vorkehrungen getroffen aber das
lasse ich natürlich nicht an mich heran
dann könnte ich glaube ich politik nicht
machen es gibt vorwürfe anderer parteien
dass gerade das klima durch die fdp im
bundestag aggressiver geworden ist so
vor allem frauenfeindlicher was sagen
sie dazu
das klima im bundestag ist glaube ich
tatsächlich so nehme ich an ich war ja
vorher nicht dabei rauer geworden seit
wir da sind denn es wird jetzt wieder
diskutiert es wird debattiert es gibt
jetzt wieder unterschiedliche meinungen
das ist in den vergangenen jahren in
diesem parlament nicht mehr normal
gewesen
man hat sich darum gestritten ob man
noch mehr oder noch viel mehr eu will
aber keiner hat gesagt wir wollen keine
eu als staat wir wollen den
nationalstaat erhalten
alle waren sich einig dass wir das klima
schützen müssen und wir sagen wir wollen
die umwelt schützen wir kritisieren dem
grunde nach wir diskutieren jetzt vor
dem komma
wir stellen deren familien politik in
frage wir stellen deren klimapolitik
infrage
wir stellen die eu-politik die euro
politik und auch die korona politik in
frage und zwar dem grunde nach das heißt
es werden harte debatten in der sache
geführt und die gewohnheit ist verloren
gegangen und deswegen trauern glaube ich
einige in sehr bequemen zeiten nach die
sie hatten ihre kam ein resümee zur
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel war sie
frauen fördernd hat sie einen weiblichen
führungsstil gehabt oder hinterlässt sie
gar nichts angela merkel hinterlässt
sehr viel wenn sie jetzt geht nämlich
das größte desaster der nachricht
geschichte in der nachkriegsgeschichte
in ungefähr allen politischen bereichen
der führungsstil der kanzlerin ist in
meinen augen vollkommen irrelevant ob
der weiblich oder männlich ist eine
katastrophe und katastrophale
verhältnisse hier in deutschland
hergestellt und darum daran werden wir
uns an an welchen welches geschlecht sie
hatte spielt dabei wirklich keine rolle